okay
being the hero is cool and all but
haven't we all wondered what it's like
to be the villain
to trash talk to do what we want when we
want and not give a
damn about what anyone thinks we're used
to seeing
rebels and badasses in sports and movies
and you might think
that esports is the last place you'd
find them
but where there's trash talk there's a
bad boy and these are the top 10 esports
bad boys
kicking off our list is a player who is
known for his
well i don't know where he's been but he
looks pretty clean to me
are you clean dick what's going on i
didn't hear a thing
i was just asking if you're gonna play a
good game
all i wanted to say was uh if any women
are looking out there and have a good
full time tonight
room 353 for pullman me and rare wolf
come along i'm talking about australian
cs go sensation
dick stacy and his quest to push the
boundaries of what's acceptable
with his katavitsa major 2019 sticker
what exactly does a dick stacey sticker
look like
in the game because i you know there's a
lot of different looking stickers and i
can only imagine what yours might look
like
i'm gonna have to wait for it to get
released man but um i think if you use
your imagination you can uh find out
what it is
uh i sent the worst one in first and i
got no emails back so uh we should be
good boys
it should be good now needless to say
valve wasn't exactly
pumped by the prospect of people
plastering dongs
all over their game so the initial
design and the one that came after was
rejected in favor of something
a little more understated meanwhile dick
stacy himself
remains anything but understated and the
fans
wouldn't have it any other way i heard
you commenting as he was talking about
malta's performance talk about
how important that his impact was to
secure the win on train
oh malta he did it all i just want to
suck his dick tonight that's that's
that's what i want to do
that's all i want to do coming in at
number nine
is one of gaming's most divisive figures
doctor disrespect aka the bulletproof
mullet
and the google prototype scope with
built that lcd led did a beat 3d sony
out of my mind you're talking about the
two dots back to back
the dock seems to have a bit of a knack
for getting out of situations that would
destroy
most people's reputations pretty much
unscathed
i mean think about it this guy filmed
inside a public bathroom
and managed to only get a short ban for
it and just
last year he got banned from the biggest
streaming platform
on the planet and nobody knows why but
somehow
all of doc's controversies have only
made him more popular
we're just getting started
[Music]
number eight on our list is csgo's
resident
[ __ ] talking smoke criminal stewie2k
man you guys are so bad man so bad
but what makes stewie's antics
forgivable and even lovable
is the fact that he can back up the [ __ ]
talk with some outstanding
gameplay and a major win we'll all
remember for
years to come look at the time there's
seven seconds
they're trying to build pyramids but
there's no more play
stewie we're going over time
what's up [ __ ]
our number seven entry is brazilian cs
goes
resident bad boy f n x now down to seven
seconds six seconds seven x in the pit
he's gonna get the one kill in that
bombing kami planted inside
oh my god what a way to win that round
now despite being the most decorated
brazilian counter-strike player of all
time
fnx is also ironically known for not
being particularly
diligent when it comes to practice
tournament performance or even getting
along with his teammates
he was playing but without any desire or
just playing because you had to
say where am i
the guy even looks the part he's a
tattered martial artist who isn't afraid
to get down and dirty on a dingy club
dance floor
but fnx isn't just a party animal
he's also an incredibly clutch player
good head shot from
fnx but they've already lost one for nx
getting a second one bombs gone down
with this oh they line up after that
he gets four kills so now pimp is left
in fact
fnx has been so instrumental to his
region's success
his roster hopping ways have become a
pretty solid predictor of
which brazilian team would be crowned
major winners spoiler alert
no fnx no major
taking the number six spot on our list
is one of the best call of duty players
of all time
skump five times
five times you have tried and you now
are finally holding it in your hands
what's this feel like it's a little bit
heavier than i thought to be honest with
you
from infamously beefing with former
optic teammate and friend crimsex
to getting fined for talking smack about
modern warfare during a podcast
skunk is never short on words to express
exactly how he feels
last and certainly trash right in the
trash
this oh warzone didn't come out on this
game worst car one of the worst cops
ever made
if you have beef with me fine like try
and beat me at the tournament there's no
need to sit here and try and play
play it out like an mma fighter like
you're not conor mcgregor bro like
we're playing call of duty at the end of
the day like still fiery temper aside
skunk has proven time and time again
that he can
always back up his trash talk on the
server look at this scoreline you know
more than anything i think
oh
[Applause]
my god
sitting at number five is doublelift
league of legends
legendary trash talking bot laner
everyone else is trash
damn there's trash all over the place
but it's not just smack talking that
made doublelift a household league name
during his career he won eight lcs
championships
making him one of the most successful
and best known n a players of
all time despite kind of not caring
sometimes
pretty much sucked for me and my team i
think
uh everyone's not playing their best
and then for me personally i feel like
i should have put myself at a higher
standard or something but
pretty much just didn't care now that
he's retired doublelift leaves behind an
impressive legacy of dumpstering his
opponents
both in game and out
[Applause]
party god mango he just doesn't have a
flow chart he literally
is such an instinctual player he just he
feels out the game sometimes
then he's going right into oh my god
mango
but all work and no play makes mango a
dull boy
and so he parties hard
in the world of esports where the
average pro is more likely to be an
embarrassing nerd than a frat boy mango
stands out as a balls to the wall
example of how you should
never let what you do for a living
define you even if your job performance
is
actually god tier are you not
entertained
mango nation stand up pound 2019
our number three pick is rainbow six
siege's big brain sensation
fabian i'm the brain i'm not the aimer i
don't have to do the shooting that's not
for me
fabian's genius strats added trophy
after trophy to his list of
accomplishments they're often known as
the best team in the world
never having that distinction until
today
penta are your world champions these two
will take the win
a 3-0 absolute destruction
but if you think fabian was the kind of
guy to quietly savor the fruits of his
victories
you'd be very wrong well the trophy fit
good in my hand last season
it might as well do this one too i mean
i do all the work because i'm the best
player in the world
it doesn't really matter how our team
plays because we play lion we press four
and we sprint then we kill people
that's how the game works right now fair
point
you wanted to face them here well who
doesn't want to face the second best
team in the world
okay fabian's reputation for talking
smack
has so far been outmashed only by his
ability to consistently win games
taking the runner-up spot on our list is
the fgc's eccentric superstar sonic fox
sonic fox looking uh give us pre-game
mind games and
with uh samia's right now not falling
for him look at that that face
not moving whatsoever sonic fox is
trying though he's trying
oh he cracked sonic fox has found
incredible success in a whole bunch of
fighting games
like mortal kombat tekken and dragon
ball fighters to name just a few
dragon ball fighters evolution 2018
champion he's done it he's done it
but aside from kicking ass in game sonic
fox fights a different kind of battle
as well as an lgbtq african-american
furry they use their public platform to
stand up for
inclusivity and equality in esports and
beyond
guess what i got to really say is that
i'm gay black
a furry pretty much everything
republican hates and
the besties first player of the whole
year i guess
thank you so much and while their
defense against the norm may have earned
sonic fox a few haters along the way
their refusal to be anything but their
best self
is nothing short of pure badassery
rounding out our list at the top spot is
one of esports greatest showman
g2's founder and once upon a time in
league of legends player
carlos ocelot rodriguez it's time to
warm up
and how do we warm up in youtube by
roasting other teams
very good even as a player ocelot was
known for his
shall we say big personality
no worries i got you
as his stream following grew so too did
his influence within his team
and some fans were convinced ocelot's
ego was to blame for
any and all of sk's shortcomings not
content with being a scapegoat
ocelot then decided to shut that [ __ ]
down in the most
epic manner possible he founded an
esports
empire if you truly believe something is
good to go
and you truly believe in the product or
the content piece or something you've
created
or in this partnership you're working on
[ __ ] push it forward you know
with g2's massive success across various
esports
it's clear that carlos's bold vision and
even bolder personality
turned out to be the driving force
behind something bigger than
any one team or even himself and in the
end all the haters now get to watch him
thrive
well done carlos for being the best ceo
so there you have our list of the top 10
esports bad boys
which one of those was your favorite
just before you go away
if you like this video make sure you
subscribe we're still on the road to
2 million subs and you can help us get
there
thanks for watching guys and i'll see
you all in the next one
probably not getting on my plane to go
to leave canada you know you know in the
movies but they're just like
i'm not getting on that plane you know
and that you don't sort of take stuff
without
whatever that felt pretty badass like i
was like watching the plane take off
on my phone and and here i am so that i
think it's pretty bad that's a little
a little bit better it's pretty cool it
certainly is i mean
it is just like i didn't get on that
plane and then you're just like damn i
didn't play for that plane ticket though
[ __ ]
listen what's more badass than wasting
money with nothing
it's the coolest [ __ ] you could possibly
do